do you know that autophagy means eating  its own self it is a process by which  cell eats its own content it's like a  cellular recycling mechanism  question is why autophagy is important  and the noble weaning work of yoshinoru  yoshumi give some idea about that  so autophagy is really important when we  are fasting for a very long time  but how does it help  so when we are fasting for very long  time  let's say we need some enzyme for our  body function  in that situation the building block of  enzyme amino acid cannot be retrieved  from food because we don't have any food  intake in that time  in that case body utilize autophagy to  recycle existing non-functional protein  to generate new enzymes or new proteins  and this is how it's a defense response  against extreme starving situations  that's one minute see you in next video